la mort en début de semaine de georges
floyd continue de susciter l'indignation
aux états unis cet afro américain décédé
à minneapolis après une violente
interpellation
malgré le couvre-feu une inculpation
pour homicide involontaire du policier
mis en cause la colère ne retombe pas
nouvelle manifestation la nuit dernière
dont la ville du drame mais aussi
ailleurs comme pénibles regarder
[Musique]
en votant difficile
holloway
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel soin de la vie de georges floyd est
importante elle apporté autant que la
mienne et comptent autant que quiconque
dans ce pays
mais voir que la vie est reprise de la
même manière faisant et compresse au
même mode et gilles garner il ya plus de
cinq ans je ne peux pas respirer est un
rappel tragique que ce n'était pas un
incident isolé mais qui fait parti d'un
simple systématique d'industrie
profondément ancrée qui existe toujours
dans ce pays son district
je me sens très très mal c'est un
spectacle est choquant le championnat en
général et moins tu parles an auparavant
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
il est ici en ce moment car comme vous
le savez nous sommes très impliqués
j'ai demandé au procureur général et au
fbi y être très attentif et de voir ce
qui se passait car c'est une très très
mauvaise chose que j'ai vu je les lui
hier soir et je n'ai pas aimé
[Musique]
c'est le dernier d'une longue série de
meurtres d'afro-américains non armée
commis par des policiers américains
les autorités américaines doivent
prendre des mesures sérieuses pour
mettre fin à ces meurtres et pour
s'assurer que justice soit faite
lorsqu'il se produise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]